I to me at this point if I get a bad
tattoo it's like you ain't gonna notice
it oh I got so many texts like I just
like I bet we're just gonna put
something else around it so I don't
stand out but I never covered up nothing
I guess my first one only god can judge
me you know I'm seeing like the most
cliched tattoo I ever had but that was
my first one i neva think I was a bit of
get it honestly I was staying with my
pops at the time and I fell under a
North Carolina
everybody got tattoos I'm talking about
in high school I'm like 16 so I remember
just sitting down and being like you
know pops I've been thinking about
getting this uh just tattoo you know I'm
saying like mad nervous about it and
surprisingly he was like which one again
I'm like oh sure you know I'm saying so
I got old school pops anything is gonna
be with it but he was like yeah I cool
he's probably like my worst tattoo now I
get to tattoo in the next I'm saying
like the next two days we went on like a
class trip to like some water park and I
was like I'm not missing this water park
my kid in the pool with the tattoos and
I like I pretty much ruined it I had to
go get it redone just like whatever put
by the next year I had gotten
three more like two stars and then one
on my chest right make it symmetrical
you know I'm saying the two stars on
both shoulders though I walk through the
valley of the shadow of death I fear no
evil
so I got that like kind of stapling on
my chest like just the whatever whatever
I was going through you know I'm saying
I knew I could do it and then I didn't
get another tattoo for probably like
seven years those years when I didn't
have tattoos like I had like a whole
iPad and screenshots that I wanted and I
basically done all that I meant like
hard I've been mapping this out for
years
I'm not even gonna lie the feminist
attack was the most painful that I have
a guy and I don't know why the feminist
with the eight-ball in the heart right
always gonna take me out for short
cuz I got something on the other side
but he didn't hurt nothing like that
like I got neck tats all the tempered
when I was getting this denim I don't
know when I first had my daughter I was
having a conversation with somebody and
I was just talking about like how I like
my outlook before women had changed a
little bit right and I always like
switch like a feminist now and I'm like
nah no I just feel differently for me
but then when I looked up what feminist
mean like you ever look up what finish
me and I feel like everybody should be a
feminist you know I'm saying it's just
basically women's rights humans rights
so I feel like everybody should be there
three at the moment the eight-balls
for section 8 no I'm saying that's me
that's my company that's everything
another term is like if you behind the
eight ball you know saying when you
behind the a boy like you're under
pressure you know I mean and that's what
I felt like I was like I was behind the
eight ball under pressure the section
anything is from the bottom that's all
of us you know I mean we all read
everybody where I'm from is from the
bottle the back is the big section eight
you know I'm saying it's going to be mom
mom think I was crazy you know saying
when I got this itch down on my back she
was like my son is officially lost his
mind anything you believe in you know
I'm saying you got to carry it on your
back you got it you got to be able to
brand it the back was the most annoying
I got a big ass back so having to sit
through on this table gorilla right here
this is just like being a beast this
represent being a beast I'm a fighter
every day I got to fight for something
you show me that we all fight you
something right here at the top is the
ski mask with the halo I feel like
that's me I feel like I'm either the
worst angel or the best heat and you
know I'm saying I'm right in between it
somewhere it's a New York license plate
you know I'm from 84 5 is the area code
and then a sec with the eight-ball
section 8 the checkerboard is for
nipsey's you feel me I got nipsey right
here I got the opportunity to meet him
on a few occasions he really inspired
like this whole section in st. Luke's
game like I seen I seen what he did with
the old put the Crenshaw shirts or not
and I'm like yeah always people in my
hood when t-shirts they might not have
ever been out there you know what I'm
saying I just like the way it was just
unified and you've seen it you know it
was him so basically all of these is
super fire to me all the MA
all of my murals and portraits here this
Mount Rushmore my boy Keith right here
in New York City to these over at bang
bang from shout out to keep I'm saying
rolling [ __ ]
Malcolm Martin and pop and for me I felt
like it was only right to put nipsey on
the same oh he got Muhammad Ali on the
back and Bob Marley
all the way on the other side Saint
Luke's is the one hospital that we got a
new bird you know I'm saying everybody
anybody came to that same hospital ok
how old you are what part of town you
live in
people typically don't leave Newburgh
and I'm saying they typically don't get
out so you want to dine in that same law
school
this whole arm is basically dedicated to
like Africa you know I'm saying everyone
not I just know I wanted to represent
like the beauty of the land and what
better way to represent that you know
beautiful woman I'm saying I got the
Nefertiti that that all pock had right
here on the wrist and the to-die-for
going across underneath I like pop cats
so much because he was getting taxing it
in a time where people wasn't getting
taxed you know I'm saying it wasn't like
a real thing in the hip-hop culture you
know I'm saying so I feel like he was
one of the first people to really to
bring that tatted look as an artist the
most recent is probably these three just
to build my idea my daughter named
across and they're all feminists and a
boy got those out in LA tattoos is like
therapeutic you know I mean like you
don't know how to deal with a pain like
that's just really don't though you
can't you could kind of just get a
tattoo you for me you could you know how
to you know how to deal with physical
pain you know I'm saying if you can't do
it emotional so like sometimes I do that
Mercy's my daughter's middle name she's
she's a flower she's precious I got that
right there and this right here this is
this is my good angel you know I'm
saying but I got the angel over the
shoulder this mother ain't my idea is
bad enough so I'll need a bad injury I'm
saying we just shut it down slow
yo broom I'm scared as hell to get my
legs that my partners they all got their
legs tatted in one arm like how you do
that especially the shinbone ring you
feel ashame ball like I can't imagine
I'm gonna try it though I'm gonna try at
least one something I still feel
incomplete I got all that is really stay
right here prime real estate yeah I'm
gonna get underrated problems like right
across the cheek those in style and
become me because this tape is that fire
I'm gonna put it right by right here
my momma hate me but Ashley gonna love
it so we good
[Music]